what are you gonna do with it if
somebody's been trying to deliver
something to you like we've been trying
to liver the truth that there's only one
God you worship Him alone not his
creation welcome to the D show one of
the most exciting purpose of life talk
shells in the world since 2006 the theme
show has been working on clearing up the
many faults misconceptions about Islam
and Muslims and at the same time
delivering the simple message of the
purpose of life in a fun and exciting
way time I was at a restaurant I was
dressed like this and the woman came to
me she said are you a rabbi so yeah I'm
a black rabbi we want you to develop a
better understanding about the pure
Islam and the real message that it
teaches peace submission surrender on
obedience to Almighty God mom says love
all mankind that's why we're sharing
this message because we want the best
for you and we want the best for all
mankind we'll see you next time God
willing on the Dean show continued to an
in peace be unto you please subscribe to
the dvo follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below please also help support the V
show by making a donation in the link
below